hi all i'm with my good friend chess
explains not in person no we're
communicating via skype and other
technologies hi there chess explained
yeah right there helper it's working
fine now the audio and all the other
technical things we've got running here
so this will be my first dual commentary
via skype video ever that I've done on
the channel and insane few so we'll put
it on both our channels we thought we'd
cover a kenneth rogoff game who is a
great economist who gave up chest one is
about 18 to go into a [ __ ] economics
economics and this is a game in nineteen
seventy six against William martes it's
up so it kicked off its Anna Lone Pine
torment 1976 it kicks off with e for
Kenneth playing white I think we should
maybe flip the boy to ask me mainly on
look at wide side here yep ok so Kenneth
playing white and his opponent played a
five and this is quite topical for the
Aronian Kramnik match because after
Knight f3 knight c6 but should be five
we had Knight f6 which a lot of players
playing efore filled with dread I think
nowadays to see my f6 yeah yeah the
problem really is that in this Berlin
defense um at this end game that from
negate aronia wrong in have been playing
in the game song the two and four it's
just yeah not much fun to play for white
it sir it's a young immediate exchange
of Queens maybe you should quickly put
it on the board just to show what we're
talking about this would happen if white
castle see on move for which is some in
a way the most vicious move but also
yeah in a way most boring move because
94 now d for 34 for wide 96 and then the
exchange on c6 detail
see 6d taxi 59 f 528 King the eighth and
we got the famous berlin wall and game
which basically around Kramnik the World
Championship title to discuss prob yes
if you can each size conspire if you can
use anyone anyone can utilize anyone no
sorry no it's very very good it's very
very solid but um as what you want you
want more sometimes than this no it's
also it's also from just objectively
very difficult to get anything um I
while ago i was looking at this opening
from some next point of view and it's
just not much fun to play for white and
it's very difficult to work out really a
consistent plan that you can that you
can play as wide so it's quite
interesting to see what Rogoff played in
this game he played on move for Queenie
to Queenie to yes interesting we I think
Nigel short sometimes basically in other
variations with Roy as a or used to as a
surprise weapon Queenie to not know
illustration maybe instance in some
other lines but Queenie eats a little
surprise so yes kaveh c4 so there's no
Knight takes e4 this is another black
player goes for d 6 which is y a bit
passive at this point I think by far the
main move from this position is Bishop
c5 which is just just more active and
and then play usually continues with
stuff like castles from both sides and
c3 this kind of kind of play would at
least you've got a full food bloody to
fight so to save got all the pieces on
the board and you don't need to worry
about yeah very complicated and somewhat
difficult to play an endgame structures
so it's an alternative if you want to
all the pieces on the board and play a
complicated game after the six all new
form it's even better for wide as you
can immediately go deform
which Rogoff also did in this game yeah
so I'm major threat I'm you've d5 that
pins looking a bit dangerous so it was
parried now with Bishop d7 no black
didn't want to release the tension in
the center anything with you if if black
takes on d4 you also need to worry about
the immediate movie 5 looks dangerous
yeah it's it at least dangerous i think
if you d 95 if it's dangerous spin on c6
it so it's a complicated position not
sure that we should analyze her deeply
here no black and black can go t3 now
maybe Oh blimey ah ok so that's that's
very oh that's very interesting hey yeah
but I was avoiding my black but I didn't
want any of this 'if I've business he
just yeah I think he was he was just
interested in getting a solid position
so he went for Bishop d7 ok and now we
get a structure which I kind of like
actually usually while prefer that to
berlin's with d fibers sort of we're
going to like him well default kind of
opening where white has center like in
the King's engine or something so yeah
and it can get very a very similar
Lechner drops back to be eight which is
so yeah always difficult to judge in
such a position should you go to be
seven or should you go back to be eight
only seven it sort of causes a bit of a
traffic jam on the King side because you
don't really know where to put this
piece later so an IP eight is often a
good idea just retreating because the
night might finding the square on c5
later yeah these weekends are squares
off to d5 so could be an issue for wine
so Bishop d free and now sort of Kings
engine style play from both sides now
after G said yeah white also could have
exchanged on d 7 which wouldn't have
been such a bad idea to get rid of the
light squared Bishop and then play c4
also quite a nice Kings Indian type of
structure where you have from
already am yeah managed to get rid of
your light squared Bishop which is
sometimes a bit of a problem piece for
white and the white squared bishops from
like is sometimes a useful attacking P
so this will also have been quite a good
option but I think you just wanted to
put more pieces to keep more pieces on
the board in the position after Bishop
e3 the bishop rd seven also looks
similar city so both move sir have their
point x yeah so g6 arm in the game um
Bishop d3 with certain preserving light
square Bishop so we have now um kind of
strange Kings engine bottom the break c5
is one of preventive now immediately
with c5 the potential future break we're
black trying to close up the Queen side
yeah actually c5 is a morph I don't like
it all here because so it completely
blocks up the position and it gives the
right sort of a free hand on both sides
of the board um I thought of it would
have expected more that leg would play
something like a five and nine eight six
yeah that would be to use that C 5
square for a piece put more Nephilim
sahni for later f5 would be with more
pressure on e4 if black paper and five
yeah it looks it looks strange so yes
this is a sort of businesses owned it
took 12 structure from a deafening and
this is the the check baloney the and I
mean which usually rides up the d4
Knight f6 c4 c5 g5g five it's quite
similar but black's pieces of somewhat
somewhat strange to place while white
white set up with Bishop d3 is very
normal so I think why just has a good
version of this opening now so 93 and 9s
exam and this night will end up on c7
trying to prepare be five but I think
this move never materialized and again
so b5 is not even parried with
you for actually white wasn't worried
just played a free hair he's going to
strike at the black porn chain maybe
yeah you're just quicker with age three
and a three-year white is actually
showing a bit that you might be able to
play on both sides of the bot you can
play before or at some point in G form I
think this is also why black when h5 now
you was worried that white would play
also g4 completely here suffocates black
so h5 is not an attacking move but more
of a prophylactic move to prevent white
from playing G form but the h5 is also
move you don't want to make really
because I was your typical break here as
like you've got the b5 and f5 and b5
looks hard to achieve the other one that
f5 and if you play h5 it's very hard to
play a 5 yeah because you've already
weakened squares like g5 yeah so like a
thought of waking up into position where
you cannot do any pawn breaks and if you
have a position without a pawn break
your position is almost always bad so
yeah that's really good rule Manchester
if you don't have the bone break in a
closed position your position is bad
yeah so it the same and white has many
breaks it's good before and it's got an
F for it both our breaks are ya arable I
think at least once again yeah so these
either the B Falk who become dangerous
or the fr yeah potentially it later with
those brains so white castle now and
then actually black wanted to trade off
the dance grandpa ships yeah ok the dark
red bishop though yeah so this is region
off it yeah the dark squared bishop is
always a funny piece of the structure
looks it looks bad on a fade but it does
some positive things from protecting the
king and protecting the dark squares and
so yeah this also leads to a somewhat
position or who look on age six which a
robot immediately exploit we three wins
a nice temple year the rock yeah so
night g8 another well the position was
closed to justify these luxurious night
maneuvers more a little bit but still
the position could be opening up very
soon with these breaks that way it has
and in fact me for starts to put the
pressure on see if I've immediately so
black I think would be loath to take
like this not only a fall dynamism but
c5 coming in so he just plays b6
reinforcing see fine the only more
digging I think would be close to
resigning yeah earlier he first opened
the position look maybe one that's very
logical to be ho could open up soon and
our bodies reinforcing a fun he's
desperate to reinforce c5 and a five in
the sky yeah both brakes are coming well
I don't think and the position like now
isn't is really a problematic and it's
hard to suggest any any great moves here
so I think that's a pretty decent job of
keeping things together but it's just
very difficult to do and the next move
that white case um well about any even
Ellis I really like because it's it's a
very flexible move them prepare standing
on the before but also the look might
switch over as your only drew here with
this green arrow is it might switch over
to the king saha especially after F for
you yeah my goats f-22 so there's
flexibility again for blasting down the
B file or the F fault very very logical
play from kenneth rogoff so no wonder he
made a very good economist hayes chess
was very logical so rook age seven um
and now he uses be take c5 it starts to
open up yeah and now he plays he's
playing on the other side now with my H
for which is great as well yeah they
after the air for break is coming up now
and this some winter tempo on g6 the the
question here is what if black would
play g5 here this would be interesting
just to block it up completely it's an
interesting what what what could be
could be wise idea here maybe a kitchen
yeah so maybe maybe he wants the e4
square for a night in the King's engine
that would be a nightmare it would be
but yeah but it looks unattractive to
allow that from from my point of view
don't I don't know what do you think
about Maya 5 yeah probably the the
positional kind of treatment and and
most likely the best movers just brewed
briefly thinking about stuff like Queen
g3 year but neither fighters just fine
and it's the best move I'm pretty sure
this is just a little trickier on the
night on g8 and this actually threatens
their 40 blood yeah blasting it open
completely ready yeah yeah maybe but
Matt 97 I think would secure the night
and then the night and h4 is really
hanging and now you don't have anything
else on 95 anyway and if you need to
play night at five anyway you better do
it with the Queen only three years
you're the creator for this is just the
best move that you suggest Queens nice
only friend I'm eyeing those targets
anyway so yeah the queen is absolutely
fine there so when g5 495 is the best
move okay in plate look at you happy not
to weakening him step further but now of
course at four right so anyone who wants
to learn about porn breaks this is like
a model game there's porn brakes on both
sides of the board with black big a
break let's see so now black tries to
challenge the activity of that rock or
on the B file yeah should be it should
be happy check whicli what happens if he
takes on their foreign place g5 winning
a piece I mean it would lean to it would
be
so suddenly left I think with it
something you need to check out with me
if you okay you've gotta believe in G 30
at least if nothing else you've got 23
and next position of the rack this but
of course Queenie 6 is something you you
need to also check out 26 take on h 45
this also looks quite powerful default I
don't care yeah that cannot take because
it's my google whoo-hoo yeah but maybe
maybe maybe there may be there from
Bishop h3 here yeah yeah now if you're
in a better position I mean sometimes
there's no need to enter complications
if logically about you sometimes you
don't want some sort of gamble with
complications so maybe elected so maybe
Queens III simply yes just adjusted a
clean solution white can if everything
else fails just play 9 a-5 next move or
drop the night back if you want and
black it's just yet consisting of horse
only so this is this is just a good move
you don't need to worry about those
technical things yeah okay so he went
rogue b8 here on the Queen recapture so
and II didn't want to keep the rooks on
he didn't mind exchanging rocks with
rook tanks be aids you know maybe he
could consider but maybe he doesn't want
any infiltration of this rook me I think
about though just concrete tactics here
look at the game he he captured on be
eight black needs to retake and now it
takes only five and its present rate
forward from here mine takes is born it
tastes unless we a c5 anyway yeah so
there's not so many options you know
Queen jeanna fine right yeah the wizard
were to go for Queen you you don't like
to see what made it firms getting very
late
yes hold to hear this fo so Queen B 2
looks active but no the King safety is
being shots pieces here off the night
takes g6 threatening rook f8 mate now
yeah and this is close to resign I think
what would a blender will get sent me
out I think there's not much else mr.
Kummer fade and now there's another
technical blow here so this Knight takes
e4 means that GA is now hanging soon um
so he can't you can't actually take that
because then f7 will drop as well so
black takes on f1 here not too many
choices and white recaptures and this is
a terrible position because this nights
hanging yeah and not just the lighter
doll for checkmate lado yeah okay took
on e5 with Jack nothing much you can do
then i'll tak wing g5 check now black ah
resins here so ya know not much you can
do if King Victor's get Shaq he'll could
be quite dangerous yeah and it yeah so
there'll be no that we no worries about
some well you can take on on d 7 will
check so there's there's yeah so so that
was it that was a cute game from kenneth
rogoff that's true do a quick overview a
summary then of this game yeah okay hmm
so it's a viable alternative to this
horrible system with 96th and Berlin or
the Russian system let's Berlin Wall
burn a little quick Queenie to is an
interesting move then Queenie to I don't
have to bear this in mind if I if I
played for like Queenie to yes so this
this seems to be very nice how it panned
out with the nice option of Bishop d7 as
well strategically in the Kings engine
you'd often want to get rid of that
he chose this continuation which worked
out very well partly because I think
black deprived himself of that c5 square
which could have used for a night out
post but now black was the becoming
devoid of can't play and as chess
explained as it is emphasized you know
black hasn't got the porn breaks but why
it's got to form brakes on both sides of
the board hitting these guys and and it
looks as though you know play on both
sides here is demonstrated with both
porn brakes causing damage in many
respects to the black position
especially after F takes e it's a
clear-cut case that the Queen's kind of
unable to rescue or help from black here
one thing we didn't mention nitey seven
is there a clear I suppose Queen f6 here
is nasty that would be quite good in
fact there'll be a pretty a mate's
winner off the check oh no not Queen f8
no pop of me no Queen 97 is it worth
mentioning um yeah maybe you should
actually take a quick look here but
Queen a particular to swing Brooke g8
Queenie Higgs Queen d6 right yeah that
that's enough to show that that's that's
not very good because once these six
drops then everything's dropping it's a
whole room echo around the pawn chain so
Queen B to it was lost anyway now
concrete mate frets appear and it's just
concrete tactics now Knight takes e4 and
it's hopeless for black hair so that was
a pretty neat game finished here pretty
neat game from Kelly if I hope you
enjoyed this experimental dual
commentary hope the audio is okay and
maybe we can if this if this goes well
maybe we can experiment with some other
ones in the future yeah so i hope this
so work out well for all the views and
the quality was fine yeah thanks for
watching ok ok I'm ok thanks everyone on
YouTube I'm thanks just explained ok
comments or questions on on both our
channels we might
have this this video soon on our
channels okay thanks very much